-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out
with John Legend.
-Hello.
-We have a lot to talk about,
the album, "Legend."
We have to talk about
"The Voice."
-It was nice though taking
a trip down memory lane.
-Yeah, I remember that band.
-Our group was special.
-It was something.
It was tight, yeah.
How is Chrissy doing?
How is the family?
-Everybody's good.
-Please give them my best.
-We're having a baby sometime
in the next few months.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congratulations.
That's so good.
-The kids are very excited.
They're back at school now.
-It's all happening.
-Luna's in first grade now.
Crazy. Crazy.
-It happens so fast, buddy.
-I know Chrissy is the chef in
the family, okay but, you --
-I can cook though. I can cook.
I can throw down.
-I know.
Well, there's a thing that you
started a little controversy.
-Controversy
as the Brits would say.
-Yes, of course, on the Internet
and on Instagram.
A little controversy
because you said that
chicken and waffles are good but
chicken and pancakes are better.
-I stand by it. I stand by it.
Y'all doubting it
because y'all haven't tried it.
[ Laughter ]
-"Chicken and pancakes are
greater than
chicken and waffles, fight me,"
is what you put.
-I did. I did.
-Yeah, that's hilarious.
-That's how we say it
on the Internet.
-But what kind of reaction
did this get?
-I got some agreement,
some skepticism.
But I know I'm right,
so, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I don't know.
I would say chicken and waffles.
-Have you ever tried
chicken and pancakes?
-I've never.
-Bubby's has some in New York.
You should try that.
-This is from Bubby's.
-Oh, this is from Bubby's.
-We actually --
We heard that you like Bubby's.
But why pancakes over waffles?
-I think it's a texture thing
because they're basically made
with the same batter --
similar batter.
But I like the soft, fluffy
texture of a pancake
with the crispy chicken.
I think it goes well.
I like the combination of the
soft and the crispy together.
I think it's better.
I'm sure Ahmir has thoughts
on this.
-Actually, we agree.
-Okay, alright.
-Tariq too?
-Yeah, there's a Bubby's
in LaGuardia,
like, in the new terminal
and they have the pancakes and
chicken.
-Hey, I didn't know you were
a spokesperson for Bubby's.
[ Laughter ]
Don't name all the locations.
Here we go.
Do you think -- You agree?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-I'm going to try this right now
because I do not agree.
I think you want
that little crunch.
-A little crunch
and a little fluffy.
-I'm going to do --
I'm doing a little syrup too.
-Mmm-mmm-mmm.
That's good chicken too.
-Wait, I can't even
slice the pancake.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
-I make a mean pancake myself.
That's our Sunday tradition
at our house.
I make pancakes every Sunday.
-That pancake's good.
-Mm-hmm.
It's a blessing.
That's delicious.
-He's right.
That's unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's actually better
than waffles.
This is a big thing.
Dude, this is a big --
This is a giant thing.
I've never done this.
-And now that
your eyes are open,
you can't see the world
any differently now.
-I feel like a new man.
-You're a new man.
-Yeah.
-You've been converted.
Welcome, welcome.
-Wow, I'm so happy!
Chicken and pancakes, who knew?
Chicken and pancakes.
And Bubby's, there's like six
locations in the city, Tariq.
There's one --
[ Laughter ]
-Tariq has a sponsored post
on Instagram.
-Bubby's.
I love following you
on all the socials.
You do have a strong opinion
about stuff.
But I do also like
obviously your music.
You do funny things
but also your activism.
And a lot of people
on the Internet have said
they want you maybe
to run for office.
-No.
-Not even thinking about it?
Not even thinking about it?
-Not even thinking about it.
I truly enjoy what I do
and I enjoy my life.
And I do not want to run
for office.
It doesn't seem fun to me.
-It doesn't. I looked on
the inner-webs to see about
this theory, and I found out
that this John Legend actually
did run for office
and win in high school.
-I ran for student body
president.
[ Audience aws ]
I was the student body president
at my high school in Ohio.
-You were?
-Yeah.
-And what did you accomplish
there as student body president?
-Well, we had to plan a lot of
events and different things.
We had a lot of meetings. I
started a peer tutoring program.
-Did you really?
-Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
-Do you remember your campaign?
Do you remember what you ran on?
-Well, I gave a speech and then
at the end, I sang a little bit.
-You had to.
-'Cause why not? Why not?
-You had to sing.
-I just sang at the end of it.
Just put a button on it at
the end, and "vote for me."
My brother actually cut my hair.
You met him backstage.
He cuts my hair still.
But back then he put
"J.R.S. for Pres" in my hair.
John Roger Stephens,
that's my real name.
-Dude, that's a slam dunk.
That's like, come on.
-That's all it took.
-Well, let's talk about --
I want to talk about "Legend."
Let's talk about this.
Here we go.
It is out today. It's out.
-It's out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can I just say, too,
it's hard enough to just release
one album.
But this is technically
two albums.
-Yeah, it's a double album.
There's 12 songs on each side.
I had a lot of time, though.
We couldn't go on tour
for a long time.
-24 songs?
-And this is what the pandemic
has brought.
I made more songs than I'm
usually used to making
for an album so I figured
let's make it a double album.
-Did you think about
spacing it out
and going like,
"I'll put one out now
and I'll take a year off"?
-No, because by the time I would
put it out, the second one,
I'd be already writing
new stuff,
and I would feel weird about
putting out old stuff.
So I was just like,
"Let's just put it all out."
-Really?
-Yeah.
-You went on the Internet and
announced the title, "Legend."
And Chrissy, your wife,
commented,
"Love to find out the album name
with everyone else.
Keeping me humble."
-See, I dispute that contention.
I told her when I was --
I was literally showing her
different versions
of the album cover.
And I told her the album was
called "Legend"
and then I reminded her of that.
She's like, "Oh, yeah, you're
probably right. I forgot."
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good impression of
Chrissy, by the way.
"Oh, yeah, you're right.
I probably forgot."
But there's some great
collaborations.
-Yes. We got Jazmine Sullivan.
-Ty Dolla $ign.
Jhene Aiko. Rapsody.
-Saweetie.
-Saweetie. Rick Ross.
-Rick Ross.
-Ledisi.
-And the music video you did
with Saweetie was really fun.
-It was very cool.
So we shot it in Miami.
And the director's idea was to
basically allow our dancers
to kind of freestyle
and be themselves.
And so the idea was
that we told them
this was the callback
for their audition.
And they were just out there
freestyling.
But we were filming it.
And then halfway through
the song, me and Saweetie
would surprise them
while they were dancing.
And we got, like, genuine,
authentic reactions from them.
It was amazing.
-It makes you just smile.
It makes you go,
"Oh, this is so fun."
-Yeah, they really loved it.
We loved it.
It was really heartwarming,
and we had a good time.
-Yeah, that's what we want.
Can we talk about "The Voice"?
-Yes.
-Season 22, September 19th
on NBC.
-I'm in it to win it.
-Camila Cabello, though.
-Camila Cabello
is our newest coach.
-And she's a friend of the show.
I know her.
I know she knows music.
-She's very smart.
She's very competitive.
I brought her on my team last
season to be my guest mentor,
and it's like
I sabotaged myself.
-You created a monster.
-I created a monster because
she's coming back
with a lot of mojo,
a lot of competitive fire.
-Didn't she get her start --
-She was on "X Factor."
-"X Factor."
-She was in that group
called Fifth Harmony.
And they were assembled on
"X Factor,"
just like One Direction was.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, she knows exactly how to --
Just even mentioning
One Direction, they go,
"Oh, my God!"
They're not coming out.
-Yes, but Simon, sometimes,
he knows how to put the groups
together.
-He's smart, yeah.
But she's lived through it,
so I think people probably
look to her and go like, "Oh,
you know, that might be the --"
-Quit making the pitch for her.
Make her make her pitch
for herself.
I got to beat this girl.
-I know.
Do you like when people
sing your songs?
Do you turn the chair
around and go --
-I am particularly tough on
people when they sing my song.
And I think
it's a weakness of mine.
It's my issue.
-'Cause why?
-I nitpick it too much
when they sing my song.
-So you're like --
Or do you go like,
"Oh, I could have sung it
like that"?
-Yeah. I had one guy that sang
my song "Glory,"
and he did such a beautiful job.
And he did new things to it
that I really loved,
and I was like --
I turned for him.
And he ended up going all
the way to the finals with me.
His name was Victor.
-How about this year?
You feeling good about it?
-I love my team this year.
We're good. I feel like we're
going to win this year.
-Alright, John Legend.
You heard it here first.
-It's going to happen.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a sneak peek at the new
season of "The Voice."
Take a look at this.
-I turned for you first,
I would like to remind you.
It's obvious
that your voice is powerful.
You have crazy range
that most male singers
could never pull off.
There was something interesting
about the little turns
in your voice that were
very soulful to me.
It sounded like a church singer
singing rock music sometimes.
Honestly.
-That's exactly what I am.
-Exactly.
-Grew up in church singing.
-Okay, we're screwed.
-I heard that then.
That's why I was so floored
by you.
You're the kind of artist
that can win "The Voice."
You can win this show.
-Here we go. Here we go.
Get ready.
John Legend, everybody.
"Legend" is out today.
-Thank you.
-And season 22 of "The Voice"
premieres September 19th on NBC.
We'll be right back with
Danielle Brooks, everybody.
Stick around.